tipping the balance on the battlefield
in Ukraine's favor
these British weapons are vital for
Ukraine giving troops the ability to hit
valuable Russia targets at a distance
with precision
we have to get back to the car now
quickly we've been told we've got four
minutes to get out of here
with Russian guns able to strike back
fast it could be fatal to stand still
no one hangs around
hours earlier Sky News went to meet
soldiers operating the multiple launch
rocket systems given to Ukraine by the
UK we're being taken to the rocket
launcher now we've been told to turn off
our mobile phones to avoid them being
tracked the location of the site is top
secret
each launcher is well hidden to avoid
detection by Russia
it's the first time anyone's been
granted access to one of the British
systems in this war we're not allowed to
say where it is other than eastern
Ukraine and identifying soldiers is
forbidden so all the way from the UK
Yeah Yeah from the UK
the UK has given Ukraine six of these
rocket launches Veterans of past Wars
winning new fans
the soldiers live in the cabin as well
as fight
Tell-Tale signs of its origin aren't
hard to find
these are the missiles it can hold 12 in
total each with a range of more than 50
miles how does it feel when you launch
them and you know you're attacking
Russia yeah
foreign
use multiple times a day
the commander even claims almost a third
of Ukraine's successes in a major
counter-offensive right now in the East
has been Thanks to British as well as
German rocket launchers
suddenly a call comes in they've got a
new mission
go right a bit one soldier says
Target locked the Commander in English
says fire
[Music]
switches flicked
we watch from a distance the target is
apparently a mobile command post
video footage has been capturing the
impact of artillery strikes similar to
the one we witnessed here Russian
armored vehicles are destroyed
Western rocket launchers are key for
Ukraine to stand a chance to counter
Russia's long-range artillery
Ukrainian soldiers even received
training in the UK on how to use the
British
systems
the soldiers constantly check encrypted
devices for new orders
another one comes in
and out they roll
it's a Relentless fight for survival and
the aim is to win
debraham Sky News in eastern Ukraine